what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today I wanted to try something a little
bit different if you follow my channel
you know that I've done a lot of videos
on omega-level and Beyond omega-level
mutant from the Marvel Universe but
today I wanted to try and cross over to
the DC side of things
the kicker about this is that DC does
not have any sort of classification
system for naming the most dangerous or
powerful threats in their universe and
so what we're going to do is simply just
apply the omega-level concept to DC's
characters now for our first installment
of this series I guess for the DC aspect
anyway we're going to focus on none
other than the Joker but of course we're
not talking about the Joker in his
regular form since as a character
without superpowers the Joker would be
nowhere near Omega level for this video
we're talking about the Joker as he
appeared in the Emperor Joker storyline
which ran through all four of DC
Superman titles during the year 2000 now
the funny thing about this is that under
normal circumstances we do our
omega-level characters by focusing on
the entire history of their powers
usually because so many of them have
been around for so long with Emperor
Joker we don't have that luxury and so
what we're going to do is the same thing
we did with the marquee of death where
we basically just run through the story
now what happens here is that we open
with Superman escaping from a cell at
arkham asylum and we find out that he's
wanted for the murder of lex luthor
although he has no recollection of even
doing this or who Lex Luthor is we
briefly see one of Superman's classic
villains mister Mixel pedelec who I'm
going to call mr. M for the remainder of
this video chasing him down but failing
to gain his attention soon after
Superman encounters one of his longtime
villains bizarro who attempts to take
him back into custody this fight leads
Superman to the office building of Lois
Lane who's the owner of a business
called Lane Corp and Lois refuses to
help Superman and he's soon taken back
into custody by bizarro and back to
Arkham Asylum now by this point it's
evident to the reader that everything is
out of place in this reality bizarro
who's usually just kind of dumb is a
member of a group calling itself the JLA
alongside poison ivy in the team of
villains that we've never seen before
Aquaman is the guy with the head of a
fish and cannot go anywhere near water
Jimmy Olsen is calling himself
gravedigger lad and hangs out in a
cemetery big and graves all day and Lois
Lane is a ball businesswoman that's
motivated by her own self-interest above
everything else we also find out that
basically everything's happening in a
continuous loop
Superman breaks out of Arkham Asylum
every day he's captured by bizarro every
day and then returned to custody just to
go through the entire process yet again
the next day
now eventually Superman is moved to a
UFO functioning as a floating prison
where he meets Hank Aaron irons a fellow
inmate this also noticed that things are
not quite right in this universe but who
have they managed to escape and are
visited by mr. an who tells him the
answer of why everything seems out of
sorts now with the help of Lois Lane who
has had a change of heart and agreed to
help Superman because she feels sorry
for him and she's rich enough to own a
spaceship I guess Superman and Hank
irons who's reclaimed his old mantle of
steel travel to the moon to find answers
they're searching for it now as a side
note here I'm not sure why Steele's
alter-ego is Hank Aaron irons instead of
a traditional John Henry irons and since
I can't find any other instances where
he was called this I guess it was just
something they did for the story where
this reality was simply just off-kilter
the only other thing that I can think of
is that the writers were trying to pay
homage to Hank Aaron the guy who held a
record for the most home runs until
Barry Bonds took steroids and then beat
his record but anyway the Superman Steel
and Lois Lane they make it to the JLA
Watchtower on the moon and Superman
battles a character named ignition one
of the JLA members who threatens to hurt
Lois this triggers Superman's memory
that he cares about Lois Lane and
reaffirms his suspicions there are huge
chunks of his memory missing now after
he defeats ignition he's once again
confronted by mr. M who restores all of
Superman's memories now for those of you
guys who don't know who mr. M is he's an
amp from the fifth dimension which
basically grants him like these crazy
vast reality-warping powers now
throughout Superman's long history he
has encountered mr. M a multitude of
times and mr. M is made it a tradition
of his to visit Superman's earth every
90 days because he just enjoys messing
around with him there's a really good
chance that if you've ever heard of mr.
Mixel pedelec it was because of Superman
the animated series but in almost all of
these instances mr. M uses his reality
warping ability to play cartoonish
pranks on Superman to torment him and
then in order to send mr. Han back to
his own dimension Superman has to trick
him into saying his own name backwards
which is basically what he does he
but when mr. M complies nothing happens
and so he explains to Superman that he's
no longer in charge of this reality at
this point we learn exactly who it is
that's pulling the strings in this
mixed-up universe as mr. M reveals and
he thought it would be fun if he gave
the Joker 1% of his power because he was
bored and wanted to see what high jinks
the jerker would be able to pull if he
were to possess just a fraction of mr.
ins reality warping abilities what
happened though is that the Joker
managed to trick mr. M into revealing a
secret name thereby giving him 99.9% of
his power which the Joker used to
recreate the universe in his own image
now in terms of what Emperor Joker is
capable of mr. M explains that he could
destroy all of reality which mr. M it
always been capable of doing but never
had because he wouldn't have anybody to
mess around with Joker on the other hand
is a homicidal mania and would have no
qualms about wiping everyone from
existence and so we also learned that
the more comfortable Joker becomes with
his abilities the stronger he'll become
and so eventually he'll be able to
control all time and space now what we
end up finding out is that the Joker for
the most part has done just that altered
the very fabric of reality and crowned
himself king of the universe and set up
a royal court consisting of the JLA the
Riddler who he's renamed enigma Harley
Quinn who he calls his babe in Waiting
because that's pretty much where she's
always been and Lex Luthor who he's
forced to serve as the court jester now
as you might expect from a psychopath
who's become virtually God Joker
does some pretty evil and crazy things
like wiping out all of the People's
Republic of China which totals to around
a billion people and then eating their
skulls out of a Chinese takeout
container with chopsticks let's say that
again all right he ate their skulls out
of a Chinese takeout container with
chopsticks that's pretty messed up now
the Joker's also uses powers to remake
the members of the real Justice League
into ridiculous caricatures of
themselves of course we already talked
about Aquaman who's basically a man fish
hybrid but Wonder Woman is a hapless
housewife the flash is still super fast
but has been satiable appetite for junk
food Martian Manhunter has been shrunken
to 3 feet tall and desires only to
destroy the earth just like Marvin the
Martian plastic man is a credit card
thief and Kyle Rayner has become the
yellow paper of Lantern now we also
learned that Joker is killed
Dick Grayson and Tim Drake and his
taking Batman prisoner and tortures him
and then kills him on a daily basis only
to bring him back to life so he can do
it all over again the next day now these
are just with a few things that the
Joker's done so we know that Emperor
Joker is definitively beyond omega-level
he can bend reality to his whims he can
kill people and resurrect them and then
change anything he wants in all of time
and space meaning that there's literally
nothing that he doesn't have the power
to do if he so wished and so to get a
sense of where Emperor Joker ranks and
the pantheon of DC characters we need
only look at the scene where Darkseid
one of the most powerful villains in the
history of DC tries to appeal to some of
the other most powerful characters in
the DC Universe including gambit one of
the guardians of the universe the wizard
Shazam
Zeus one of the gods of the repent
beyond the highfather and Phantom
Stranger basically telling them that the
Joker is in possession of the anti-life
equation which would basically allow him
to control the minds of all sentient
beings
now Darkseid quickly finds out that he's
arrived too late and that all these
super powerful beings have already had
their consciousness replaced by the
Joker and so Darkseid is subsequently
subdued by the Joker as well and so yeah
if we're Joker is crazy powerful would
all of a sudden be can do in addition to
just kind of being insane and so what
happens from here is that Superman
rescues Batman but Lois Lane makes a
deal with Joker to become his new babe
in waiting and then betrays Superman
and so Joker imprisons Batman once again
and forces Superman to live at a
television show for Joker's amusement
where everyone close to the Man of Steel
including Supergirl Steele and Superboy
are destroyed whenever he gets too close
to them now Superman is soon transported
to a remote location in space by the
specter who's basically the vengeful arm
of God and informs him that Joker is
going to destroy the entire universe and
that only Superman can stop him because
spectres on the verge of being trapped
by the Joker as well
now to give you some perspective of just
how powerful the spectre is and by
extension how powerful Emperor Joker is
and DC Comics presents number 29
Superman punch the spectre and
absolutely nothing happened not a single
thing and so Superman is then returned
to the Joker's TV show but he tells the
Joker that he knows the world that he's
created is not real and that he'll never
stop fighting to bring the world back
now this display of bravery and
the rest of the Justice League members
to remember their past selves and then
revert back into the traditional forms I
know it's lazy its kind of lazy riding
you know it's not the best plot ever but
it works but after this Lois Lane
switches sides again my god man this
girl switches sides more than a high
school girl but after this Lois Lane
switches sides again and then takes up
Superman's side because she realizes
that he's right about the universe that
Joker created being a lie
and so she frees Superman from his
restraints and tells him to defeat the
Joker now when Joker finds out about her
betrayal he tries to kill her and grows
himself into gigantic proportions but
Superman literally flies up through the
Joker's body and out of his forehead
of course this particular action of
Superman doesn't actually kill the Joker
since he's nearly indestructible he's
basically God now following this
Superman is once again visited by mr. M
who tells him that the only way to
defeat Emperor Joker is to figure out
the rules that Joker's playing by now of
course Superman eventually figures out
that the Joker has not yet erased Batman
from existence because without Batman
The Joker's existence itself is
meaningless and so what he's confronted
with this realization the Joker just
simply lashes out and tries to kill
Batman but realizes that he can't do it
now after repeated attempts Joker
realizes the Superman is correct and
this realization actually causes the
Joker to lose his powers and he reverts
back to his normal form now after the
Joker is ousted Superman mr. an
inspector reformed the universe the way
it should be but Batman's left broken
due the memories of the repeated torture
death and resurrection that he had to
endure and so feeling that Bruce
deserves to be free of his pain and
fearing that he would not survive in
this broken state Superman absorbs those
memories so the Batman can function
normally and the Joker is imprisoned in
the slab metahuman prison in New York
and so that pretty much wraps his story
Adam is really just kind of how it ends
but I wanted to imagine for a minute
what Emperor Joker would have truly been
capable of this story was written in the
year 2000 and Superman comics were
fairly light-hearted so while the Joker
does do some crazy stuff and even
torture and kill Batman
most of the things Joker did emphasized
the more cartoonish and goofy aspects of
his character instead of those truly
dark and evil sadistic parts and so I
just want to point out what we had seen
if Emperor Joker had been written by a
writer that really played into the
darker more demented aspects of the
Joker and that we would see him do some
pretty
heinous stuff and remember him as one of
the most powerful evil forces in DC
Comics but at any rate for the brief
moment that we had Emperor Joker in
comics he was without a doubt one of the
most powerful characters that we've ever
seen in the history of DC's publications
anybody that could bend the minds of
some of DC's most powerful characters
basically their virtual gods including
the spectre hi father Zeus bend all
their minds to their will and then
control and destroy all of time and
space is clearly a character that's
beyond omega-level or at least he would
be if such a thing existed in DC Comics
but without being said guys we're going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end let me know how you guys feel about
expanding this whole you know
omega-level thing into DC I think it's
cool I think it's a pretty cool idea it
allows us to tap into the power levels
of characters that we wouldn't normally
tap into but let me know what you guys
say down in the comment section leave a
comment below and yeah I'll catch you
guys later
[Music]
you